- [Woman] It's an experiment in,
in human consciousness.
- [Man] It's like pushing the
reset button of your soul.
- [Girl] If that makes sense.
- [Woman] It's glitter
bombs that will live inside
every one of your
orifices for weeks.
- [Announcer] Wait, what?
From the creators of
Bannaroo and Outside Lands
and the network that
made it cool to say
- Gee
- [Announcer] Comes a
comedy and music mashup
of festival proportions.
Comedy Central presents
Colossal Cluster Fest
featuring Jerry Seinfeld,
Kevin Hart,
Bill Burr,
Sarah Silverman,
Chris Hardwick,
and a special appearance
by your actual soulmate.
- Wheeeeeeee!
Fun times.
- [Announcer] Musical
performances by Ice Cube,
Tegan and Sara,
Chromeo,
Preservation Hall Jazz Band,
Vince Staples,
and more with those
(beep) glitter bombs.
Plus Bob Odenkirk, Tig
Notaro, Fred Armisen,
Lil Dicky, Moshe Kasher, 2
Dope Queens, Chris Gethard,
Ginger Minj, Bob the Drag
Queen, Michelle Buteau,
James Adomian, Jay Larson,
Joe Derosa, Nate Bargatze,
guy in a horse mask.
Oh, and did we mention,
Jerry Seinfeld!
- I don't know what
any of this is.
- [Announcer] But
wait, there's more!
Hannibal Buress,
will be there and
so will Broad City,
Reggie Watts and
Maya Rudolph's Prince
cover band, Princess.
Plus Roy Wood Jr.,
Rachel Bloom, Anna Faris,
How Did This Get Made Podcast,
and Superjam featuring Les
Claypool's Bastard Jazz.
Explore the worlds of
your favorite comedies
like South Park.
- Honey (beep)
- [Announcer] Seinfeld
- Good luck with all that.
- [Announcer] And It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia.
- [Bar Crowd] Straight up,
straight up in Philadelphia.
- [Announcer] Comedy
Central presents
Colossal Cluster Fest.
June second, third and
fourth in San Fransisco.
- Ohhh, ohhhh
- I will be there.
- What up?
(crowd cheers)
- Can we go now, can
we just be there,
can we just be there now?
How do we get there?
- See you at Cluster Fest!